♪ ♪
>> Dagen: AS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FIELDS BIPARTISAN
BLOWBACK FROM THEIR BOTCHED
AFGHANISTAN WITHDRAWAL,
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS HAS
ALL BUT DISAPPEARED FROM PUBLIC
VIEW, THE SECOND IN COMMAND TO
BRAG ABOUT BEING THE LAST PERSON
IN THE ROOM, AND THAT MAYBE ON
PURPOSE.
JOE CONCHA LABELING KAMALA
HARRIS AS THE ABSENTEE VP BY
DESIGN.
"SINCE HARRIS TOOK OFFICE SHE IS
YET TO HOLD EVEN ONE FORMAL SOLO
PRESS CONFERENCE, NOT ONE.
IT'S ALSO BEEN WEEKS SINCE
HARRIS SAT DOWN FOR A ONE-ON-ONE
INTERVIEW.
THERE'S A REASON FOR THAT."
GREG, IS KAMALA HARRIS A
LIABILITY FOR THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OR ARE THEY A
LIABILITY TO HER FUTURE
POLITICAL CAREER.
>> Greg: TONIGHT WILL BE DOING
AN IN-DEPTH INVESTIGATION INTO
HER WHEREABOUTS, WE HAVEN'T
FOUND HER.
THERE WILL BE LOTS OF NEW
BREAKING -- SHE WENT FROM THE
STAR PUPIL, YOU KNOW, TO THE
WEIRD ONTO YOU KEEP IN THE
ATTIC.
IT'S AN AMAZING TRANSITION.
VOTED BASICALLY MOST LIKELY TO
BE PRESIDENT AND SHE CAN BARELY
GET THE FREE WI-FI AT ARBY'S.
I DON'T KNOW -- I HAVE A THEORY
I WROTE DOWN HERE.
HERE IS MY THEORY.
THE ADMINISTRATION GOT BAD SO
FAST, KEEPING HER HEAD AND IS
PREFERABLE SO SHE DOESN'T GET
SMEARED BY JOE'S FAILURES AND
THEY ARE WAITING FOR THE RIGHT
TIME TO BREAK THE GLASS AND TAKE
HER OUT.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW BAD SHE IS,
DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO ASSUME IT
CAN'T BE ANY WORSE THAN THIS.
AS MY THEORY.
>> Will: I LIKE YOUR THEORY
AND I HAVE A FEELING I KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO BREAK THAT
GLASS, WHEN RACIAL POLITICS
BREAK MAKE THEIR WAY BACK TO THE
FOREFRONT OF THE CONVERSATION.
IF I AM KAMALA HARRIS DO RIGHT
NOW, I AM EXTREMELY OFFENDED
BECAUSE YOU HAVE BEEN USED.
NOW THAT THEY DON'T NEED OR THEY
HAVE SHELVED HER BECAUSE HER
APPROVAL RATING IS NEGATIVE 19
AND IT'S CLEAR THAT WHENEVER SHE
IS OUT FRONT SHE DOES HERNANDEZ
A LIABILITY TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IF I SAY, I WASN'T A LIABILITY
FOR YOU WHEN YOU NEEDED TO GET
ELECTED SO KAMALA HAS A RIGHT TO
BE VERY, VERY UPSET BUT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS IN A
VERY, VERY TOUGH POSITION.
DO WE ADMIT WE USED KAMALA TO
GET ELECTED OR DO WE RUN HER
BACK OUT?
>> Dagen: UNTIL THE ANGER AND
RAGE OVER THIS AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWAL FADES, HOPEFULLY IT
DOESN'T, THEY'VE GOT TO KEEP HER
HEAD AND BECAUSE SHE IS CLEARLY
NOT VERY GOOD ON HER FEET.
LESTER HOLT, WHEN SHE CUT OFF
THE FEMALE JOURNALIST, SHE'S NOT
A GOOD ENOUGH LIAR.
SHE CAN'T TAP DANCE AROUND THIS
DISASTER WELL ENOUGH TO PUT HER
OTHER IN PUBLIC.
>> Geraldo: I THINK YOU HAVE
TO REMEMBER HER HISTORIC
SIGNIFICANCE.
FIRST WOMAN IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
REMEMBER THAT A HANDWRITTEN
MEMBER OF THE BURDEN THAT SHE
CARRIES AND HOW SHE WAS SO
MISUSED ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THEY TOTALLY DICTATED HER
MOVEMENT AND SHE TOOK THE FALL
FOR IT.
NOW SHE IS SO NEGATIVELY
PERCEIVED, NOW HER POPULARITY
WAS 34%.
THAT'S EXTRAORDINARILY LOW FOR
SOMEONE SO HISTORIC WHO WAS
SUPPOSED TO PROP UP OLD JOE SO
WHAT I THINK THIS IS NOW IS A
PRAGMATIC, RUTHLESSLY PRAGMATIC
DECISION, I KEEP HER ON THE LOW
DOWN RIGHT NOW, WHEN THE TIME
COMES IF IT IS ABOUT RACE YOU
CAN ALWAYS BRING HER BACK.
>> Dagen: SHE PROVE SHE CAN
HANDLE HERSELF IN THOSE
INTERVIEWS.
AGAIN, OKAY, SHE'S GOT THE CROWN
ON HER HEAD BUT SHE'S GOT TO
KEEP IT THERE AND SHE STEPPED ON
IT.
>> Shannon: SHE WAS A GREAT
FIT, CHECKED SOME SERIOUS BOXES,
EXCITING FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT
REMEMBER DURING THE PRIMARY, SHE
WASN'T GREAT ON THE PRIMARY
DEBATE, WHILE SHE WAS A GOOD FIT
ON THE TICKET, WHETHER SHE CAN
BE A GOOD LEADER AND MANAGE
THINGS, SHE'S GOT THE WORST
ASSIGNMENT WHICH COULD BE THE
BORDER.
IT'S AN UNSOLVABLE PROBLEM.
SHE'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE A
PROFESSIONAL TIEBREAKER, GIVEN
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE SENATE,
GO UP THERE AND BREAK TIES
WHENEVER IT MATTERS BUT IT'S NOT
LIKE SHE SHOWS THE PRIMARY
PROCESS, THAT SHE WAS UP TO
TAKING THAT NEXT STEP.
>> Dagen: DID YOU HAVE
SOMETHING YOU WANTED TO SAY?
>> Greg: I MISS HER LAUGH, IT
ALWAYS BRIGHTENED MY DAY
WHENEVER SHE WOULD LAUGH.
DO YOU GUYS WATCH STORAGE WARS?
I KEEP THINKING I'M GOING TO
WATCH AN EPISODE AND THEY'RE
GOING TO OPEN UP A CONTAINER AND
SHE WILL LEAP OUT.
BEFORE "90 DAY FIANCE" IS K